on va l'avoir trouvé tout de suite en
réaction notre correspondant pas à
berlin emmanuel sheyi emmanuel bonjour
on sait cette décision extrêmement
difficile pour l'allemagne elle ne sera
pas on imagine sans conséquence mais au
vu des derniers développements les
allemands ont donc décidé de franchir
cette nouvelle étape dans cette mise sur
pause du projet de gazoduc nord stream 2
oui tout à fait une décision qui était
en fait sur sur toutes les lèvres qui
était appelé par toutes les puissances
occidentales alliées à l'allemagne et
une décision qui a énormément tarder
elle est arrivée aujourd'hui alors que
la seule savez s'était toujours montré
très frileux déjà à nommer le projet
nord stream 2 comme pouvant faire partie
des possibles sanctions économiques qui
seraient éventuellement porter contre la
russie et puis c'est intéressant aussi
dans la formulation il explique qu'il a
demandé à son ministre de l'économie de
retirer ce certificat qui avaient été
données aux au pipeline au gazoduc nord
stream 2 alors que dans les fêtes robert
avec le ministre de l'économie vert
était lui convaincu depuis des mois même
depuis des années deux en fait de la
nécessité de ne pas donner plus d'accès
aux marchés européens au gaz russe donc
c'est assez intéressant c'est la
formulation employée par par leur chute
c'est plutôt le contraire qui s'est
passé puisque c'est lui qui a été plutôt
convaincu par part c'est par les membres
de son gouvernement de coalition
notamment les verts de la nécessité
finalement de suspendre ce projet un
projet qui avait obtenu un certificat en
octobre dernier sur le gouvernement d'un
gala merkel et puis ce ce gazoduc north
stream 2 qui est intéressant à savoir
c'est qu'il a été construit par gazprom
gazprom qui a reçu des crédits des
crédits énorme des banques allemandes 1
milliard de crédit pour la construction
de ce gazoduc ces crédits avaient été
autorisées à l'époque par le
gouvernement de l'ancien chancelier
gerhard schröder gerhard schröder qui
est désormais à la tête du conseil
d'administration de gazprom il
évidemment des conséquences économiques
et peut-être dès qu'on dit des
conséquences énergétique sur l'allemagne
mais la ministre des affaires étrangères
anna lena berlocq avait assuré que
l'allemagne était prête à faire face à
ses conséquences et la présidente de la
commission européenne où seul afin d re
d'alien avait prévenu déjà avait rassuré
déjà ce week-end au cours de la
conférence sur la sécurité à munich que
l'europe était prête non seulement à se
diversifier cantat quant à ces sources
d'énergie mais aussi à se rendre plus
indépendante des sources énergétiques
russes qu'elles utilisent en ce moment
merci beaucoup et emmanuel en direct
donc de de berlin